I get emails every day from people
saying that I did something for them
whether it was cuz they read a book or
because I answered something for them of
course you have to start with yourself
because you're if you're not in a good
place you're not gonna help anybody but
I think that in our space because we
have people that have built things that
are touched by everybody we think that
means change the world it is so easy to
change the world one by one every person
in here could do some good [ __ ] every
day you can and that is changing the
world and so I think that the way we're
viewing changed the world in this space
is you've got to create charity:water
or build something as big as Facebook I
think it could be simplified
dramatically you know you can really
change the world in a lot of ways and I
think it's much more scalable one-on-one
and much more executable every person in
here can do it not every person here is
gonna make a product used by everybody
in the world